[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
number 63 january 16
2021 we are now going to answer
your questions as has become our habit
yes all right should we do that yes yes
yes we shall i
i sorry i'm distracted i have lost
control of the animals lost control of
the animals you seem to have
dog treats there that's for the dog
you're not planning this walk their
house
really really not but i was hoping
that uh we could get her to to jump for
treats on camera but uh
she was she was mostly not paying
attention i see yes
um yeah all right here we go a few
questions from
last time first then question from the
discord server and then
launching right into questions from this
last hour
this question is from the temperance
movement
regarding europe's portal and darkhorse
podcast fans discord server
wokism has similars
i did not re-read these before starting
today wokism has similarities to the
temperance movement against alcohol of
the 1860s and to 1920s that gave us
prohibition
that was also strongly strongest in the
anglosphere does it offer any useful
lessons
that's interesting you know we've i i
have not heard that before but i've
heard it um
called the new puritanism yeah uh and
obviously prohibition is sort of a you
know a piece
of a puritan approach to the world
uh restrictionist and such um i mean i
think there
is a kind of a lack of
self-awareness and an appeal you know
it basically does have to do with a sort
of utopianism
and um you know an acknowledgement
of the imperfection of the system that
that is not an indictment of
its capacity to be to be excellent
is going to be key to navigating and
anybody who wants to hold us to an
impossible standard
um is going to find that we haven't met
it and therefore use that to justify
uh whatever crackdown they're interested
in so yeah i do think there's something
there
as for anything prescriptive i'm not
sure
i'm not sure that the parallel is close
enough to know what to take from it but
yes what they're doing
if if they got their way it would
backfire no question about it
um okay i guess i'm i'm not
totally sure what you just said that was
that was comparing wilkism to the
temperance movement just in in that
they were both fail well guaranteed to
fail
because of an unrealisticness about you
know
purity you know purity is up against
alcohol
the right solution is to uh
prohibit it completely right that
that's the same sort of childish uh
thinking that one sees in wokism
and so yes i see a parallel no i don't
think it's especially close but
it's going to backfire because any any
uh any aspiration to
some kind of uh perfect standard
um is going to suffer the same failure
okay um yeah i think that i think
there's
a fair bit more to do here but um i'm
not
i'm sort of not sure how to riff with
that so let's let's just move on
uh if you see something else no i just i
um i'm just thrown by that answer so
let's just move on
okay um not gonna lie i understand blm
a lot more since trump voters were
declared second-class citizens
i don't agree with their communist
rhetoric but understanding that i was
but i now understand that i was never
part of the system
um could you repeat the first one
unfortunately we've lost our screen so i
can't see the question yeah
zach is there any way for you to show
not to
people are you there yeah um so you know
dad can't see this anymore because we
had
yet more unreasonable
not going to lie understanding blm a lot
more since trump voters were declared
second-class citizens
don't agree with their communist
rhetoric but understanding that it was
never part of the system so you know
basically
you know someone who you know i'm
guessing is
is white saying um
i i am now recognizing what it is
what it feels like um to live as a
second class citizen
and you know without without making any
claims about um
you know the history being the same or
any of that that there is there is an
analog
and um getting outraged at
the persistence of uh oppression
is one response that we can understand
yeah i mean and you know i think in some
ways this is
this has been our message all along is
that there is something to which people
on the fringes are responding the system
is not
responsive to us it frankly doesn't give
a damn about us we are an inconvenience
that it
deals with only as needed and
the idea that our reaction to the
corruption of our system
is to divide into two factions that
appear opposed to each other rather than
to recognize that the enemy is the
corruption that
messed up the system in the first place
is an absurdity but yeah of course
um and you know and i mean terrific if
more of us can take that you know can
can recognize that
and say ah okay we are we are having
enemies created for us
in order to divide us uh you know those
those who are not the elite wielding
power and
uh that is that is them winning and you
know some of it at least is likely to be
by design
yeah i said something i think it was in
the the jeremy lee quinn
episode that i've now seen a number of
people pick up on
uh i said um we are fiercely divided so
that we will not be fiercely united yeah
you did so that's good
and uh you know i really think that is
what's going on is that um
the anger is at something and we have
been manipulated into believing it's
about something else so that we won't
discover our common interests
yeah now exactly what um you know what
occupy
was doing and i think you know i i know
precious little about it but what i
think
the at least the origins of tea party
were trying to do as well right
the very very in uh origins were a lot
were very similar to what inspired
occupy um
and uh you know it's almost as if we
need a unity movement
you know a unity you should start such a
thing yeah now unity movement is
different than
unity tm which is what the blue team has
been uh
oh they trademarked the word or the file
the word and the color they've
they've captured it and rebranded it so
that unity is now about making
war on the deplorables but well we can
all get behind that can't we
no we cannot the lack of security at the
capitol
so these are questions from last week
when we were talking about
um the insurrection that happened three
days prior
yeah uh the lack of security at the
capitol was either gross incompetent
negligence or an intentional soft target
for political
theater love you guys thanks for your
efforts and just a second question
the second statement that is similar to
that
again from last week on a scale of one
to flat earth
how much of a conspiracy is it that the
capital was deliberately woefully
understaffed and underprotected to
create pretext for patriot act style
power consolidation
can we seriously not protect our capital
um
i would say we don't know there's
certainly
conspicuous stuff about the way the
capital was left unguarded including
um please to uh have it be
uh better guarded in light of what might
be unfolding in advance that were unmet
yes so
yeah there is a lot to wonder about
there was also apparently
you know an antifa leader who has been
arrested who was
part of it um so anyway that's actually
been demonstrated this year yes
and uh so anyway what i would say is i i
don't
think we know what happened at the
capitol
i don't think any of that actually
alters the conclusion
that apparently annoyed some people um
in the first part of the podcast
about what uh the right patriotic thing
to do at this moment is
in order to make us strongest going
forward
um i think the answer to that question
is still clear it's
you know as i said up top it's destined
to anger almost everyone at one level or
another but
um yep but yes this is where we are
something unfolded we may never know the
full story of what happened and why
um but the basic point is we're here and
we're vulnerable
and the first thing to do is to to
protect the ship
yep all right final question from
last week um oh this is going to have
been
just this is just a comment uh and it's
going to have been a response to the
question about how
and what we feed our animals uh musher
here
looks like there's some dog sledding in
oregon find a musher and see if you can
get in on a bulk buy of raw fish or raw
chicken
my 25 sibes never heard it
contracted that way but i guess
siberians get a mix of dry food and raw
chicken or fish
but you do need a dedicated freezer
that's one of the
one of the few things i miss is that we
had a chest freezer when we lived in
washington state we don't hear
yes we fled our chest freezer we fled
our chest forward
our chest freezer unfortunately forced
to flee our chest freezer yes
we actually sold it to our neighbors
well
um it was a methodical fleeing yes very
careful
um okay this from the discord server
this week uh heather
in the last q a number 62 you mentioned
acupuncture and chiropractic rather
seriously whereas i the person asking
the question then got upvoted
whereas i understand there to be
pseudo-scientific and generally quackery
am i missing something so you know
i would love to spend a lot more time on
this actually but
um let me say that um
the first time i i just tried
acupuncture for the first time a couple
of months ago
and uh chiropracty maybe
six years ago or so and in both cases
when they were suggested by people i
respected
i had this response of really like given
what i've described to you
you think that could help because i sort
of had the same the same
sense and i think you know like i said
in the q a last week in every field
there are people who don't know what
they're doing
and in some some fields are more prone
to having
those who don't know what they're doing
obscure that fact with a lot of woo-woo
and that can make it seem like the
entire field is based on nothing
and i think chiropracti for instance um
has uh a a legitimate reputation
of being too often interested and like
cracking
you know cracking vertebrae uh and it's
not
safe and those you know extreme
manipulations are generally
um not warranted and i have um
i you know i i did visit a chiropractor
who turned out to be interested in those
sorts of manipulations and
i didn't go back um yeah you were messed
up once
yeah um and then i also found someone um
actually this is up in olympia who was
just absolutely terrific and you know
really
really understood what the body was and
used some combination of you know
diagnostics with
with x-rays and also did a lot of
traction um
if you're you know various parts of your
spine in my case it was cervical spine
so sort of like neck traction
um but also manipulations that were very
gentle no you know no
sudden cracking movements that really
responded
to an understanding of all of the
systems together and i guess that is
what any of these
any of these traditions that are either
ancient
or you know or newer but are persistent
and um and seem to produce results tend
to be
more holistic than reductionist and you
know holistic also has the sort of
woo-woo reputation but uh the
reductionist model of medicine has yes
gotten us the successes of things like
antibiotics and vaccines and surgeries
and it's also gotten us in part to a
place where we have
very hard time getting diagnoses that
are appropriate and
um have a very hard time seeing people
as singular complex systems as opposed
to a collection of parts and forgetting
about emergence
so um there's a lot more to say about
chiropractic
with regard to acupuncture i will just
say
this um that the the
the guy that i was sent to is actually
um both
trained in traditional um
acupuncture in i think i think it's
taiwan if memory serves
and he also has an md from stanford and
his father has the same and they
themselves are ethnically um chinese i
believe or taiwanese
uh and that you know the fact that
there's a lineage tradition there
of both having the western medical
approach
and the chinese acupuncture approach
and having this having this doctor say
to me
you know i can speak both languages i
don't practice western medicine at this
point but i
you know if you know you me you're
trained as a scientist if you want to
hear this
in the language of science i can do it
that way or i can you know speak in the
language of acupuncture the fact is that
um you know they don't exactly translate
into each other's languages
but there is now a robust
uh peer-reviewed western literature
demonstrating the efficacy of
acupuncture for some sorts of situations
you know i'm sure it is used and
actually dr hong who i've seen
um has said you know you know i talked
to him about
some other thing that i was experiencing
said yeah i don't think that's what
acupuncture will
i don't think anyone will do any good
for that so you you need
you need a practitioner who understands
the limits of what they're doing
and also if possible who's capable of
speaking across disciplines and so
you know is interested in and willing to
put their work to the test of for
instance science
um so i agree with a lot of what you've
said but i also think
it you know it misses the most important
uh
aspect of this okay um
so what i would argue is
that the central problem is that
our western scientific
medical viewpoint is
mechanistically based and these
alternative practices are some of them
are garbage
those that are not garbage are
metaphorical truths and what that means
is that there are patterns to be deduced
about what therapies work
and the explanations that are delivered
for why they work are non-literal
and that the problem is western medicine
has a particular reaction to that
which is that which is not literal is
not true
which is false and that the problem
is the reason that you say there's no
translation is because there is no
translation
nor should there be so that is to say um
you know
acupuncture is based on the flow of
something called chi through the body
she does not actually exist but a model
of qi
allows a practitioner to actually alter
what they do
so that it is more effective at
alleviating the uh the condition
there is undoubtedly some mechanism
under it that is that could be
elucidated and there's clinical evidence
that for
particular kinds of injuries acupuncture
is effective
uh more so than the pharmaceutical
response of western medicine in reducing
pain right and
there's also the flip side which is that
our western
mechanistic it's only true if it's
literal version of this
has plenty of garbage in it right sure
so the idea
that the need for orthodontia in
a large fraction of western children is
the result of
bad genes having gotten
into the system and therefore leaving
people with unfortunately shaped
jaws that need to have their teeth
forcibly reorganized that's just pure
nonsense as is the idea that chemical
imbalances
are uh you know spreading through the
population
like wildfire as is nothing to be done
for it but treatment with neuroleptics
and antidepressants right
it's people basically telling you they
have the cure for something they're not
particularly inclined to find
the root cause of same thing for
the rampant need for glasses amongst
young people these are all the result of
evolutionary novelty
the subject of our book and the point is
these novel influences result in our
ill-prepared bodies malfunctioning
and an ancient tradition that basically
allows itself to attempt to cure that
which it does not mechanistically
understand especially if it's a
long-standing tradition
there is bound to be a lot of truth in
it even if that truth is not housed at
the mechanistic level that science can
easily recognize it but
when you begin to understand how much we
clearly have wrong
in the western you know pointy-headed
scientific way of doing this
and how much is apparently right in
these metaphorical traditions that are
long-standing and
have delivered an awful lot of of
therapy
the answer is well yeah questioner
you're
you're missing something what you're
missing is that a metaphorical tradition
may be able to alleviate your pain for
reasons that none of us can
mechanistically explain and that doesn't
mean it's not
alleviated or that it was you know all
in your head or anything like it
right there can be um empirical results
even absent a theoretical explanation
for why they work
right literally false metaphorically
true is good enough if it
uh allows you to function in ways that
you couldn't before
and so anyway i hope that one day we see
some kind of an enlightened uh
approach to medicine in which we begin
to honor
just simply the understanding the
clinicians used to have about cause and
effect that didn't you know
it was great if you had the mechanism
but let's face it medicine was born
long before we had the ability to peer
into all of these systems in detail it
was gross anatomy and nothing below that
level so
anyway noticing patterns is good enough
to get you to therapies that work
ancient traditions are liable to have a
lot of truth in them if they're
expensive
and anyway there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with recognizing
that yeah
good um
okay first question from this last hour
i have not read this it looks like it's
two parts um
from 1950 excuse me from 1950 to 1970
black home ownership increased from 30
to 70 percent
black home ownership is currently 70 but
at a higher debt ratio
i don't know if that means a higher debt
ratio than it was in 1970 probably
you could say that the last 50 years
were also bad for blacks so the pass may
not be great
but it is greater what has changed in
america in 40 years is that stocks went
from mostly having voting rights and
dividends to mostly not
not sure what that sentence means this
transitioned the stock market from being
an investment to a ponzi scheme
evidence is that google voting and
non-voting stock price are
oh the google voting and non-voting
stock are priced the same
very interesting perspective yeah very
very interesting i think i understand
now
um yeah so to the extent i mean it is it
is kind of
two questions but yeah yeah well the
idea being voting rights
and dividends meant that the value of
the stock was very closely
tied to the actual value of the company
whereas
there's a game that gets played yeah
with respect to volatility and profit
where basically what it is that's being
traded just all the new
vehicles that's not the right term yeah
yeah all
the new financial vehicles that have
been created sure and and the
you know what i would say is you know
ultimately
the market uh internalizes all of the
things that you could actually analyze
it internalizes them into the actual
price and what's left is
luck and insider information and so the
answer
but again just it's just like with the
models then right it's just like you
know
you know i i feel lucky i guess to have
you know stumbled upon this paper that
we were talking about in the last hour
where they actually you know left some
of the bodies on the surface
you know for me to be like ah well you
know your assumptions are unjustified
and your assumptions
you know your results were mandated by
your assumptions
um but you know if if everything is
hidden
then then the rest of us are left with
no information but what did you just say
the
insider trade insider and insider
information right insider information is
one of these things
like regulatory capture where there's a
narrow definition
where if you didn't violate the law you
know if it's not provably insider
information then yeah
it's just information but the fact is
you know
there's a threshold there's lots of
information that people
trade on the basis of that no one is
ever convicted for doing so
but it's clear that the information was
not available
generally yeah yeah um
and i think you know to this person's
first point about um
black home ownership increasing from 30
to 70 from 1950 to 1970 and we're taking
we're taking your word for that that
sounds like totally plausible numbers
to me um that it stagnated starting in
1970 or you know maybe it continued to
go up and it's gone back down
which would actually be my guess you
know that didn't go up to like 90 but
um uh and i guess that percentage
is about what percentage of black
families
own their homes i actually don't know
what that percentage means because 70
actually seems high like i i would have
i would have guessed that fewer than 70
american families
at large in their homes um so i'm not
i'm not actually totally sure exactly
what these percentages are referring to
but um certainly
if um even if um say black and white
home ownership were equivalent
at the percentage level but uh the debt
ratio was higher
for black people there and you know
they're in a worse situation
and i mean i guess the i don't have the
numbers at my fingertips
at all but the number that we you know
will frequently
hear about is that just you know
household wealth family wealth is far
lower in black families than in white
families and that that you know that is
um you know presumably not entirely but
there's a large fraction of explanatory
power in that
um due to slavery and jim crow yeah well
that yeah in my opinion this is where
the whole conversation should have gone
rather than pretending that everything
is modern racism that's just hiding in
every interaction
the answer is well how much is actually
causally related
to these things which actually are
unique right
um but doesn't require active racism in
the present
and you're just you're losing your
audience you're losing a bunch of people
who should be your natural
sport has been terribly ruined but
allies
yeah right like there are a lot of
people out here who see
the ongoing effects of historic racism
and are not going to sign on to your
it's racist or it's anti-racist
get in the canoe garbage sure in fact
one of the things
um you know uh over both conversations
that jeremy lee quinn and i
had we both remarked on the fact that we
have been
led to believe by those on the extreme
left
that you know there's rampant white
supremacy everywhere and the
one thing you don't meet is actual
people who will defend
you know one race winning out over
another he's he found one
yeah in the wild that one in the wild
yeah um so you know
finally after looking for a very long
period of time he met one in the wild so
you know it isn't and i would never have
said they don't exist i would say
they're very very rare which means
what has been reflected in our
experience meeting people across the
political spectrum
is that if there's one thing that people
agree on in principle
it's that nobody should have an
advantage over anybody else no
population should be advantaged
over another based on some immutable
demographic right characteristics we
have
you know great differences over how fair
we think the current system is
at that level but in terms of people who
actually want it to be unfair they're
very very rare i think i think they're
legitimate uh disagreements about you
know what would confer advantage
as well um and uh you know that
that that will become a sticking point
if we ever get mature enough to get back
to a reasonable conversation
you know as i have frequently said you
can often cover
half the distance if you can figure out
what part you actually disagree on and
if you can get everybody in the room to
say look
whatever the truth of modernity is we
don't want
people to have advantage on the basis of
their skin color right we can debate
whether they do
or to what degree they do but we
shouldn't
be you know the reasonable people all
agree that you shouldn't get an
advantage based on your skin color yeah
and the point is then that leaves a
question of like okay
well how fair are things at that level
and that's a discussion that's much
easier to have rather than
having to fight you know the whole thing
right
um so yep in any case
all right um
this is a this is a new pledge of
allegiance it looks like
i pledge allegiance to the official
narrative of the united states of
america
and to the corporate media for which it
stands one nation under thumb
divided by echo chambers with chaos and
injustice for all
amen and a women yep so that's
that's good um and you could
hear in my that's good the butt coming
which is the um
amen and a women which you know there is
a lot of garbagey stuff going on with
woke policing of language
language um in the house like in
congress
but this amen and a women thing i think
wasn't that and it was john mcwhorter
who tweeted something saying uh well i
don't i don't remember exactly why but
basically this is a
colloquialism that comes out of southern
baptist preaching
i think is what he said that basically
this is uh this is something that is
said in black churches in the south this
is not some neologism
of the of the woke so you know get over
this particular one
yeah no i think actually it's great that
it turned out that way yeah um
you know it's a it's a mini act of civil
disobedience
you know with a you know with a wink
which is yeah how it should be done
yeah because like yeah i'm also relieved
you know like
it's it's hard it's hard to find a hope
in the idiocy that is
um spouted by the the
what did wokistan by the citizens of
pakistan
um but they've certainly confused the
presence of
men in words for being gendered a lot of
times
and it turns out that this isn't their
doing like this is not they did not
this was not them thinking that the men
in amen was about
men they're making uh an error of
historic proportions
they are yeah all right
uh my thesis oh this is totally
different okay my thesis
a game theory approach for the
relationship of the california
red-legged frog and the invasive
bullfrog
the latter dominates the former this is
this person's hypothesis i think
the latter dominance the former accepted
ephemeral sites
i will be adding brett's design
constraint case for mapping this
relationship
do you have thoughts um okay so we've
got the invasive bullet frog that came
in from the east and is basically
where it exists it is mostly
decimating populations of any frog
that is taking up similar uh has a
similar niche and in california it's
red-legged fry actually red-legged frog
gets all the way up to washington so
that's all along the west coast
um unless boy i just i don't i don't
have my amphibian book right here i
don't remember if that's a subspecies
um or its own species um
invasive bullfrog dominates the formers
this hypothesis accepted ephemeral sites
that would be interesting i don't know
if that's true i don't think you don't
need to talk in terms of game theory and
i don't know exactly what you're talking
about with regard to
design constraint unless it's just like
what kind of trade-off it is yeah um
yeah i guess that's it but it's you know
that's that would be
that sounds like an actual excellent
predictive ecological hypothesis and you
don't have to
use you know any additional terminology
to say okay
i think actually the red-legged frog uh
will out-compete the bullfrog at
ephemeral sites i'm be curious to know
why you think that and
it might well be true so i would just
point out
two things there could be a trade-off
that has shifted for some reason that
would cause
this change in who is competitively
dominant i would be especially
likely to imagine humans you know if
humans were changing
the relative prevalence of ephemeral to
persistent pawns or something like that
which is something humans are likely to
do you that's one reason you could get
this shift
well i mean but no i mean the shift is
the bullfrogs are new they just got
brought in recently that's what i was
going to say so the alternative would be
that humans
have solved a dispersal problem and it
solved a problem for the frogs not the
people or the other frogs right yeah
solved the dispersal problems that the
frogs couldn't solve for themselves
yeah they got over the continental
divide right and that
uh basically the frogs who are
competitively dominant
um that is the bullfrogs are
um in the circumstances
in they are paying a cost in some place
that it doesn't matter relative to their
new competitor
right so it's a it's a they're getting
away with something that
has a cost in their natural habitat but
is uh
it's a freebie where they are so yeah
anyway so something like that and you
might i mean you might expect even if
this didn't exist at the beginning when
the
when the bullfrogs were first introduced
that california red-legged frogs and and
those few others that are directly
competing with bullfrogs
would begin to experience character
displacement or begin to do niche
partitioning and you know
find those you know edge places or edge
characters
where they can compete successfully and
the bullfrog is
just even marginally less good at it and
that's that's where you win yep
all right one of two why are these
separated separated yeah i don't know
why
um okay so
if consciousness can emerge from a
complex system like a human
why can't it emerge from things more
complex than humans independent of our
ability to interface with them
things like stars planets weather and
even concepts such as love truth or
justice
the old world gods personified michio
kaku
used to talk about the ant versus the
highway in regards to tears of
civilization
and humans barely even registering as
type zero
so before you riff on this um
i want to say that uh stars planets
and weather are now more complex than
humans not by a lot they're far
they're far simpler yeah and that's
pretty much where i was going yeah um
yeah they're far simpler um
and therefore it is unlikely to emerge
um on the kinds of time scales that
we're talking about on the other hand
you could make a credible argument
that life emerging
from stardust
resulting after selection in
brains complex enough that consciousness
emerges especially
downstream of sociality that that is
stars more or less manifesting
consciousness so the point is
the very process you're looking for is
the very one we've got so it's not like
by the same logic where you're like you
know the dog is run by sunlight
right like everyone i've met is right
the dog and the girls and me and all of
us like we're all solar powered
you just have to take it back far enough
right absolutely including nuclear
reactors
yeah yeah we can let them puzzle on how
nuclear reactors are solar powered but
they are
yeah uh so but how about you know that
so you know the old word gods
the old world gods personified doesn't
quite fit unless you
unless you take a really long long
perspective
um but then concepts such as love truth
or justice well you know those are
manifestations of our consciousness
yeah that's you know that's that's what
those are
that's what those are yeah yep um
all right next question
western culture may be entering its
senescent phase
where do we currently see antagonistic
plyotrophy i love the idea of birthing
something new
but won't human culture always be a
complex adaptive system
if yes isn't antagonistic plyotropy with
late harms inevitable
yep i've made that argument a few times
on here
it sounds like maybe you weren't present
for it but the basic idea is the exact
same
phenomenon and in this case we can
identify
what what the influences are that do
this but the very fact
that a technology a novel technology can
be very profitable
for decades before we ever discover
what's dangerous about it
means that because our political system
is influenced so heavily by what is
profitable by the time we figure out
what's
dangerous about it we can't undo it so
that process
will result in uh society decohering
hence the idea that we would need to
birth something new
solving the senescence problem in
exactly the same way a biological system
does it and the point is
what that would look like is not kaboom
we all disappear and some other society
replaces us
it would involve basically the selective
export of that which we understand
which is useful but isolating out the
part that is legacy code
and so that could look like us you know
taking a good look at where we're headed
and realizing
um you know down that path is
destruction
and destruction is not good and
therefore in the interests of the future
we should rally against
a 2.0 version of what we've got which
had lots of stuff right
and anyway it would be very natural and
the problem is everybody's so
busy making a killing from the present
system that they are loath to give up
the opportunity
for such a small benefit as having a
future
tiny benefits such a little benefit i
mean they won't even live to see it
it's terrible to heather
uh which did you find more mentally
challenging sitting in meditation with
tiknot han or getting your phd
love from berlin germany um
gosh my answer will no doubt irritate
those people who actually meditate
um on a regular basis but um i didn't i
so for those of you who missed the
reference i was lucky enough to be part
of a
uh what was called a buddhist artist
retreat when i was 18 when i was still
in high school
um that tiknot han uh was leading and we
did three
sitting walk sitting meditations in one
walking meditation every day
um but you know this wasn't one of these
you know month-long or even week-long
retreats of total silence
and you know effective like you know 12
hours a day of meditation we did
i don't remember how long they were but
45 minutes or an hour
each um and uh
and yes there was that meant that there
were you know something between three
and four hours of meditation every day
but that amount of silence
um and the ability to silence
you know not just the ability to but the
encouragement to really silence your
brain
for that amount of time really suited me
very very well
and i think actually doing that training
helped make me um
an even better animal behaviorist than i
would have been otherwise probably
um and they just they just don't
compare so you know honestly when i hear
people talk about how difficult
meditation is
i always imagine that they're talking
about these you know these retreats
of um effectively
endless meditation at almost every
moment of every day
for days on end something which doesn't
appeal to me i've never tried and i
imagine would be very hard
but this that wasn't hard at all and
certainly with the whole process of
of graduate school and getting the phd
had its challenges
so i'm just saying that was harder
um how do you feel about andrew yang
running for
new york city mayor is this a signal
that the u.s won't be ready for unity or
a third-party run in 2024.
can you try to get data on the events of
january 6th in dc to andrew so he can
move beyond mainstream media
race talking points um well i'm
i'm uh frightened that
uh andrew running for mayor is not a
good idea
and that it uh will spend
the very uh special value that he has
frivolously um so you know i
in order to do what he did uh in the
presidential race
he has to have um
characteristics you know he had you know
he's he's not somebody who loves
the spotlight and yet he was able to
capture people's imaginations and
uh to get them fired up and you know
the question is what is the downside of
that superpower
and one of the downsides i suspect
has to do with him being too much
of a believer and the idea that he's
going to be able
to win the office of mayor of
new york city which he might and uh
rescue new york city which he probably
can't
and that his ability to do good in the
world would be
um enhanced by his attempt to do this
i'm doubtful
so maybe he sees something that i don't
but um
look there's a lot of talk about third
parties and things and i frankly i think
we would be wise for all of those of us
who are thinking
about something in this direction uh
to put our heads together and figure out
what the best
move is i think you know a wouldn't be a
moment too soon obviously and b um
there has never been greater openness to
uh you know at least not in in
living memory there has not been greater
openness to this ever
so let's uh strike while the iron is hot
um and you know andrew would be uh
perfectly well suited
to such a thing if he was open to it but
um you know i think
frankly he he bought the dnc's line
about what they were up to and why he
needed to be a good soldier and he
played that role and
somehow he's not learning the lesson of
uh
that they used him and then spit them
out and
i don't know andrew if you're out there
think very carefully about what you're
doing and
let's consider a bigger play
i understand your reasoning but he trump
did not commit an impeachable offense
doing the wrong thing for the right
reasons that's a terrible precedent
well i don't agree with that i think
a this is not
a jury trial right the congress is
empowered to do this
and it will not do so lightly under any
circumstances
and uh you know eric has been pointing
to
this legal concept of direction by
indirection
in which what the president said was
clearly to be taken as an invitation
to a show of strength relative to
federal power he was not doing this on
the basis
of his having proved his case in any
court
and so you know the fact is he has
greater responsibility to the nation
than any of the rest of us to be very
careful about what he encourages people
to do
he very clearly encouraged people
to march on the capitol did he encourage
them to act
violently not explicitly but he did
encourage them to act strongly and i
think if you look at his speech it's
very clear
what he meant and you know at some level
this is
all about um
his i hate to say it but his very
fragile ego
he needs to have won the election and
therefore um
anything is legitimate in his mind
uh that points in the direction so
um anyway i disagree with you i do think
he did something
uh impeachable that a conviction would
not be a miscarriage of justice that it
is both necessary and reasonable
um and and i hope to see it but again i
would hope to see it in a way
that spares the nation and therefore
trump of the trials that i suspect would
be an abomination that will follow
from him returning to private life and
um not having the protection of a pardon
all right well done thank you
i'm looking for the question here we go
i feel like people who are warning about
the dangers of wokism
and those who warn about the apocalypse
of climate change walk a similar path
has anti-woke already fallen into the
trap of sounding too hyperbolic to be
honest
well the question seems to assume uh
that we will be on board with the idea
that
uh climate change could be apocalyptic
as hyperbole
which um we we aren't we don't agree
with the fact that we
uh question some of the models
that have been generated um that the
conclusions of which are part of what
the evidence is
for there being a possible climate
change apocalypse on the horizon
does not mean um that we can't also
point to a considerable amount of
evidence uh suggesting that we've got a
real problem
and um that there is really no excuse
for
not fixing that problem quickly and in
fact you know i'm
i'm proud of what we've done on dark
horse talking about
the evidence that there is something
very serious and novel going on
including
yaml craters including glacial retreat
and the plumes of co2 being released
we've also talked about the fascinating
and possibly
very positive sign that there may be a
negative feedback that retards the
release
of methane from the arctic as a result
of sea level rise creating greater
pressure that holds
the the clathrates stably
and you know so yes there's hyperbolic
stuff
in the climate stuff and the more model
based it is
the greater the number of bodies that
can be buried
on the other hand there's stuff you can
check yourself and the fact is
i think all of us who have lived you
know in places for
long enough to monitor uh the trends
know that something is changing now do
things change without human beings they
do
but it's changing in a predicted
direction it is concordant with
uh a reduction in glaciers etc now the
changes are speeding up
yeah the changes are speeding up on the
other hand you know kilimanjaro should
be
free of glaciers by now and it isn't
right so
this gives you an ability to calibrate
what you really need to be careful of
though
is that the positive feedbacks can take
you from one place to some place
way down the road very very quickly and
so
you know really i have my eye very
closely
on the danger of a positive feedback
with respect to methane release from the
arctic that is where this is going to
get
away from us right quick but we have
no no known breaks no no possible no
this will take us this will take it
completely out of human control
and so anyway you know i'm not looking
forward to when i told you so on that
front we need to stay
far short of that which means we need to
you know we need to do all kinds of
things i've advocated for
uh us uh you know going full speed ahead
to get
fusion power because fusion power is the
one technology that would actually
allow us to reverse global warming not
just halt it but reverse the process
um so you know if you get nothing else
from this
i would argue that is a nuanced
i think balanced presentation of the
various things that belong in that
analysis and you are right
when one enters climate uh change
circles you very often get
only you know you get uh confirmation
bias
across the entire landscape and that's
very reasonable anti-scientific
conversational tone right and it is in
it is certain to be true that to the
extent that there will be data that goes
both ways and there will of course be
data that goes both ways
that the field is inhospitable to the
data that goes against its central
conclusion
you won't find it published right even
even if there are and there surely are
many many many good and honest
scientists who find things that they
didn't expect and don't
really doesn't match their understanding
of the universe even if they are trying
to get those things published
it's probably harder and harder to do so
right yeah
um so in any case there's a nuanced way
to do this
the field is not being good about it
that is dangerous in and of itself
the parallel between climate and wokism
uh i'm leery of but i would say yeah
we've said from the beginning
there's an element of truth right that
you know for example what we said a few
minutes ago about
um that there is a lot of stuff
downstream of slavery and jim crow
that has impacts today that's not the
same thing as saying
racism is rampant today right it's
saying the consequences of past racism
are still with us
which is a very different conversation
so yes you know nuance in all things
where
nuance is reasonable yep
in regards to truth in media i think we
need something new
a cabal of untouchables worthy and
capable of the job of recognizing
truth-tellers of all types
people like the two of you awarding an
incorruptible badge of honor
well the problem is spotting people who
are
capable of the job and uh
you know not getting upended and i would
just say that's not
it's not an easy job to figure out who's
for real and durable and
uncorruptable yeah it's not it's not
it's really not uh what are we at zach
in terms of time
oh good um okay i'm going to do three
more here because we had a ton of
questions this time some really good
ones
do three more then go over to this
hour's directions
the questions why is the prime directive
not a valid answer to fermi's paradox
alternatively if there's a genuine
cover-up then it's possible we have
interactions all the time but the
public-facing data is total garbage and
worthless
uh okay i think i understand this
question so the prime directive
um being basically don't talk about
fight club
yes that's it um which i don't see its
relevance here
um no the prime directive is you go man
[Laughter]
um is uh don't mess with
um don't mess with the cultures you
encounter
traveling through the galaxy right yeah
is there a better way of putting it
probably um
yeah so well basically don't mess yeah
the answer is
in order for the prime directive uh to
be the answer there would have to be
agreement across the galaxy
exactly it might explain why we haven't
run into some
but not all presumably right yeah or we
you know some cultures could just be uh
mad and giving us the cold shoulder i
don't know
yeah silent treatment something um
okay but okay your point about the
public-facing data well sure
um it could be that there's a conspiracy
that keeps us from
knowing about uh evidence of
extraterrestrials
um but you know it's not the kind of
thing you would want to believe just
because it could be true
yeah so that would require quite a lot
of uh
that required quite a lot of work and
you know and like
if if we can try to do like theory of
mind on these
almost certainly fictional um
extraterrestrials like
what's in it for them that they are
engaging in some secret
um secret thing with the earth and
um and if we don't have an answer there
you know what is why is it that whoever
the officials would be on earth are so
interested in obscuring this from
like it just there's a lot of narrative
there that needs to
be consistent with one another for that
to make sense and it's not it's
totally impossible but um it just
requires a lot of
a lot of epic cycles yeah on the other
hand there's been a lot of interesting
stuff that has emerged in the last
couple years
so who knows we'll see yeah but it's
definitely not parsimonious as a
hypothesis
is it possible that asymptomatic cases
are more transmissible because people
don't act like they have the virus and
thus are more likely to transmit it
if yes if there's if there's
infectiousness if you are an if if viral
load
is anything of an indicator of
infectiousness for instance right and
uh it does seem that viral load is
pretty comparable between
never symptomatic pre-symptomatic and
fully symptomatic people which is
frankly shocking to me then
then yes the fact that people who don't
feel sick are less likely to
do the things they're supposed to do and
quarantine themselves and all of this
um uh could increase
their infectiousness as a result of
their behavior rather than
as a function of anything that's
intrinsic to the virus itself
is there any chance that these new
coveted strains are more contagious not
because of a major shift in their
composition
but because humans overall health stats
have been lowered due to lockdowns and
inactivity
well that is interesting no i don't
think so it's an interesting hypothesis
though
i mean but you know before you go um
it's also true
that um you know millions of people have
died
worldwide yeah at this point millions of
people have died now
who you know presumably there's lots of
people who just haven't run into it yet
uh but a lot of people who ran into it
who were easily taken out have been
taken out and so at some level you would
also expect at a global level that
people are
more resistant rather than less yeah
so good point i also think that
so i shouldn't say this because given
the
level of scientific malpractice we've
seen
is it possible for those who are telling
us about these new strains and their
increased
transmissibility have botched the job in
some yes
massive way yes in which case yes we
could be seeing
you know the sort of gross demographics
of spread could be about a weakened
population something like that i do also
wonder why suddenly we're hearing about
all of these new mutant strains right
and again
it fits the uh pattern of uh is there an
audience is there a powerful audience
that wants to hear about new strains
that justify
you know various interventions maybe so
the thing's been evolving from day one
let's just say the story about new
strains has not made
sense i'm not saying that the new
strains
don't exist and i mean new strains will
exist constantly
and it is very plausible that you would
get something like
increased transmissibility but um
the story that is circulated about it is
said in a way that doesn't add up
and for one thing the idea you know that
it's a british thing and we've seen
hints of it here but we're still going
to get it under control
no if it's no but there's but there's a
few of them now there's there's a really
bad one being reported out of my house
um and you know it's not clear well is
that was that what was there
in the spring and was killing so many
people or is this somehow
like i mean you know it's not somehow
new it's it's evolving
all the time and every time it spreads
into any new place it's gonna then
continue to
you know it's adaptively radiating as
things that evolved do
yep um and at what point do we call it a
new strain or do we choose to recognize
it well
the fact that we are right now like in a
point in time
identifying all these new strains
strikes me as
very very strange i agree it it is odd
yeah and again to our previous point
about
we really needed a number of populations
that existed in enough isolation that we
could study this stuff in detail and
know exactly what it meant because
really we're just flying blind
yeah yeah that's true and actually this
so this uh this paper
uh looking at people in brunei you know
it wasn't an isolated population that i
was talking about in the first
hour um but had it
was as close as i've seen for a pretty
big population
to being able to actually track a pretty
large number of people
so i think some of these efforts did
happen
mostly not here mostly not in the u.s
hail professors do you have thoughts on
revisiting the legalization of dueling
if folks are getting riled about what we
called fighting words
um dueling yes well i mean
you know it has its place to be sure to
be sure
all right maybe it doesn't have its
place but um yeah i don't know
it's a serious question yes i i i think
it should be revived
ceremonially somewhere dueling
do like nerf dueling or something like
that
i'm feel certain that i spent a lot of
my time i'll have my childhood nerf
dealing with my
brother is that right yeah yeah we
definitely had nerf bats and
i pummel each other quite a lot am i
correct neither of you were killed
no neither of us were killed all right
so that yeah does you know
say positive things about the form
it does although i think neither of our
forms were particularly um
we weren't skilled we weren't trained
and they were dueling
yeah yeah all right all right um
men in predatory reproductive mode leave
paternally imprinted genes in favor of
embryonic development
is predatory mode genetically determined
what genes will mend with predatory
inheritance
but using investment strategy leave
how can genes know the dad's intent in
the moment of the act does that even
know
thanks for all i love you both keep it
up so this is from echo this is in
response to
you you know immediately um i think it
was in the last
q a we were talking about um genomic
imprinting
and the idea that a
a baby is
a baby's genome actually keeps track
keeps track as if it's conscious which
of course it's not
of which parent various copies of the
genes came from and that maternally
imprinted genes for instance
tend to put the brakes on excess pulling
of resources
from mom and making the head too big
before birth whereas paternally
imprinted genes
um tend to try to pull more resources
from mom
and um you had specifically been talking
about mating system perhaps being a
mitigating factor here and the question
here is well how
how are the the genes that might be
paternally imprinted
going to keep track of or know what you
know what what kind of mating system dad
is in
um well the answer to that might be
things like um you know keeping track of
different kinds of sperm that are
showing up in
in the mom but um also like how do
like regardless of what kind of mating
system
um in general like what about the
individual
man and his intentions how how could a
paternally imprinted gene possibly know
well i mean look so there's a question
about what we
know and i don't know the answer to the
question about how it's done but
i do want to correct one thing okay i am
somewhat dubious
that head size would be downstream
of uh a imprinted gene
because the baby in question that is to
say
the offspring of the male has every
interest in the mother surviving birth
because it is very unlikely to survive
if the mother dies in childbirth
yeah so i i don't think i made that up
but i don't have the reference
i'm just saying absolutely it could be
but there's going to have to be some
sort of subtle logic to make that
sure work but in general the logic is
that a uh a father's genes if a father
is not sticking with the mother in other
words if this is the only offspring
of his that she is going to bear then
his interest in her distributing her
resources across her entire brood is
lower
right right so anyway there's a lot of
really important stuff downstream from
that
uh logic and that logic is very robust
right but to what degree
can social system and mating system
actually
can genomic imprinting actually be
informed
by the mating system in which the
players live right and so this is why i
want to say
what we need is a proof of concept right
we need a demonstration that something
mechanistic can do the job
yeah rather than a demonstration of
what it is that does the job right so
what i would argue is
for example there are
a courting
is a ritual enforced by
females to make sure males are actually
interested in commitment that is to say
if it takes uh months to
end up engaging in reproductive behavior
with somebody
that's a that's a long con and a very
expensive one
for a male to engage in if he's just
going to flee
right whereas it's a test not just of
intention but of actual stability
like even if you really want to be able
to stay with her if everything in your
world
is constantly in chaos she's going to
see that at some point right you know
and this and this what you just said
about courtship you know this but you
know
like i discovered courtship in these
little tiny poison frogs that i studied
right like you know courtship has a role
to play
across any any sexually reproducing
organism
in which there is going to be parental
care by both players
right so given that and given that there
are physiological changes that accompany
the state of mind that result in
extended courtship in other words
a person in love is in a physiologically
different state
right that physiological difference
state we now know has chemical
signatures
so could those chemical signatures be
used to
imprint the careful imprint
i mean print isn't quite what you no i
think i do mean imprint
in other words if a male is going to
produce during his lifetime
two different kinds of sperm right those
that accompany
a a fleeting relationship in which he
intends to invest nothing and therefore
his interests are
uh in that offspring taking as much
resources it can safely get from the
mother and not saving any for
his uh his offspring's half siblings
or a relationship in which he intends to
invest in which case his
interests are very symmetrical with hers
then the point is the presence or
absence of those chemicals that come
along with
uh with love could be
uh used to basically turn
on and off different genes right just
the same way
the whole argument i think it's not
exactly imprinting but like a tag like a
like a vasopressin
mediated epigenetic tag there you go on
sperm uh that indicate you know in love
or not
right now i would argue this is an exact
analog
for what we imagine happens in the case
where a gene just simply decides whether
it comes from the male parent or the
female
parent right which is the usual meaning
of imprinting right
so anyway whether or not separate from
the other meaning that most people have
even printing of like
the duck sees conrad lorenz and imprints
on him as his mom yep
yep um so anyway proof of concept
it's very easy to build a system that
can recognize these things and
and uh react differently without
changing the underlying genetic
sequences is the point
yeah cool i like it the woke will not
compromise
they will persecute their opposition to
the ends of the earth among the woke
there is no forgiveness
only vengeance i fear that certainly
among
the extremists that is true i think
i think they need to be shown that there
is
a more interesting and wonderful way
because you know at the moment they feel
ascendant and that they're winning
and no there's there's not going to be
any forgiveness um
if that's if that's where they are like
you're right but um
there has to be some reveal of why this
is actually
is not the promised land is not going to
bring them the
the peace and and love that they are
hoping for no
but in some sense i think they have to
be stopped because
of course they do what will happen if we
don't is that right but but some of
some of they have to be stopped can be
done by changing some
fraction of their minds ah well it
depends yes it can
some fraction of the audience for that
stuff can be
you know they're truly committed or very
unlikely to
uh to reverse course but there are
people i don't think that's true
no because we we've seen we we've seen
people who were
um sort of mildly playing along
and um and sort of woke up at some point
yeah that's what i mean that's that's
what i would call the audience
but no like i i think that's not fair
and i think that leaves people feeling
even more boxed in
if you say you know those who those who
speak this
this ideology are lost to me
and you know there's sort of no
redemption i mean i just we have to we
have to
offer redemption at all stages and
assume that it's possible not just offer
it's not ours to offer but like
assume that just about anyone and i
won't say anyone but just about anyone
is capable of uh doing
a turnabout and i'm not including in
that
at the point that the writing is really
truly finally on the wall for everyone
having people come forth and say oh it
turns out i was wrong all along it's
like no there
you know there will have to be some some
uh
effects for the truly bad behavior yeah
i don't think i don't think we disagree
yeah i think a lot of people are saying
things they don't exactly believe
or they are speculating on what might be
true and
there is some core that's driving this
yes
but you know yes yeah people have to be
have to have the ability to
realize that what they're saying is
nonsense and to come around and
yeah we should welcome that
okay uh zach where are we at you are
about an hour okay we'll go
a little farther i'm not sure these next
questions um
i'm not sure what to do with them what
role do you think apophenia
is playing in the warped world views of
the fringes of both left and right
love from new orleans i'm now going to
look up apophenia
yeah okay um i think
quadrophenia is playing some role
in the perception belief system of the
who
and possibly the cdc apophenia the
perception
of or belief and connectedness among
unrelated phenomena
okay so just sort of a conflating
cause and correlation and you know
seeing and what was the question
what is it what is its role in you don't
want to riff on the who some right
oh i got it okay the punch line of that
joke was and the cdc
okay yep got it um
where were we oh wait here we are oh
the question was what role do you think
apophenia is playing in the warped world
views of the fringes of both left and
right love from new orleans
um i mean i guess apophenia sounds like
you know it's a
like a fancy sounding word that just
sort of sounds like
a scientific illiteracy and you know
failure to do logic and so i'm not you
know
um no i think it goes beyond that okay
um
i think this is alluding to the tendency
of the mind to find
connections that are very tenuous and to
establish them in something other than
an agnostic
form it's all of our god-given
uh pattern recognition without any
breaks and
care yeah so there are there are results
for example about uh
birds chickens uh becoming superstitious
about patterns that we know to be random
because the experiment made them random
on a conveyor belt with stones and
pieces of corn and all
yeah um so the tendency to find pattern
where it isn't
is a common one but i think the point is
here
when the mind has really good high
quality information
when the signal-to-noise ratio is high
it does a much better job
when the noise dominates signal then the
mind is looking for any indication of
what might be and so it's very prone to
fall into this nonsense and so i think
the collapse of our
academic architecture and our media
architecture and
the whole sense-making apparatus is
leaving
the mind lashing about trying to find
some pattern that would make sense of it
and frankly i think we also see that you
know we've talked at length about
um the fact that people who may be
just simply feeling not at home in their
own skin
because the era is uh
is broken deciding ah it must be that i
was born in the wrong body this kind of
thing
that is the conclusion it's a plausible
answer if everything feels wrong then
maybe it's because i've just
you know i'm i'm a woman and i've been
walking through life as a man right
that's a
that's a hypothesis i'm depressed and i
have a chemical imbalance
right i'm depressed and i have a
chemical imbalance exactly and so
um anyway i think i think it has a lot
to do with this
and that understanding the the fact that
that property goes
up as the quality of your information
goes down yeah well and i mean those
examples
reveal how easily uh at least one sector
of the economy
can take advantage of you know
we got a pill for that they got a pill
for everything
including lots of stuff they've created
themselves and
um you know the pharmaceutical company
seems tailor-made for
uh for apple fenia yeah i don't know if
you're in
your i guess your illusion was
intentional to that
uh i think it was the first iphone
commercial there's an app for that
you remember this no back before we were
all used to
the way the smartphone would work the
idea was
oh there's a lot of things you want to
do and there's an app for you know oh
yeah
you want to keep track of your you know
pet's medication schedule there's an
app for that right so there's a pill for
us no i don't think about that
no no i mean i i i perfect i think that
many people have
suggested that there's a pill for that
um i don't think i'm
anywhere close to the first there um i
think it well predates
iphone as much as iphones have also
contributed mightily to our current
problem
please get michael tracy on the show
he's a lot of insight in the current
topic thanks
um yeah we've so we've talked about this
and um
that's this is this is on you to figure
out
if you're gonna do that um should online
journal bibliographies link to comments
from cited authors
philo should online journal
bibliographies link to comments from
cited authors
phylomemetics the evolution of
anti-evolution policies
science i don't know if this is two
different questions
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what this means
i don't either yeah okay so i like the
title the evolution
of anti-evolution policies yeah um so it
sounds like there's
potentially an interesting article in
science and then the
first part of the question um
comments from sighted authors i don't
know
i don't know about that um that's
interesting you know do you want to turn
um do you want to actively transform you
know use the additional
uh functionality of the online
environment to
really make a paper or something that
has become a conversation
as opposed to you know it was
an outgrowth of just the limits of of
hard copy journals where you would have
something published and then if it was
contentious or if some of the people
cited you know either some of the people
sighted said you got my work wrong or
some other people in the field said i
think this is
crap the next issue of the journal would
have a
rejoinder and there'd be another one and
then at some point hopefully it would
stop
um and you certainly have
a quicker back and forth it's possible
now and also the online journals
make it much easier to track down
articles because they're you know
references because they're
generally hot linked but
comments from authors who were cited
so that feels like it's a slippery slope
that is
beyond anything that has yet happened i
don't know i don't know if it is
happening maybe that's what the
reference here is
is a place where it's happening no i
don't think so i think it's a reference
to our discussion and the idea
that um the abuse of source material
uh is revealed by your work but if the
authors of that source material were in
a position to say hey actually you use
my reference badly that would be good
yeah on the other hand i agree with you
it's a slippery slope issue because
at the point that you you know let's
suppose the paper gets hot
right and people are suddenly citing it
well then the authors of all of the
articles
that have been cited by it have an
interest in intervening and getting
their paper looked at and so you're
going to have some kind of a
yeah an appalling no and they're also
there also becomes
an expectation perhaps you know and for
you know for most scientists they
don't get cited enough that this would
become onerous maybe but um
if if you can comment whenever you are
cited
the expectation might quickly become if
you haven't commented that it
has the impremature of your like it has
your
your your premature has it has your
acceptance on it and
um that is certainly not the case now
and that would be that would be a
dangerous
thing to set in motion i think yeah the
idea
you could have an intermediate thing
okay you could have something
where a an author that believes their
work
is being misused has a mechanism
to highlight and signal the editors of
the journal i believe my work is being
misused and if the editors of the
journal find the complaint credible
then it depends that would increase so i
like that
um you you've now added to the workload
of the generally unpaid
um editors of journals and you know we
already have a totally legitimate and
long needed push
to basically make all the scientific
literature open open source
that's not quite the right language but
um
you know how it's never been clear what
the economics of that
are you know this work is largely unpaid
done by academics the peer review is
done by academics sometimes the editors
are paid but often not
and um you know publishing
all of this takes a lot of work and if
the scientific literature is to be made
available
to the people who funded it which is to
say for the most part you know the
american taxpayers
which it should be we then need
additional sort of federal funding for
the creation of the scientific
literature publication machine yes yeah
so we need academics who suck less and
we do
treat them better oh yeah
yeah okay and uh and federal funding for
science journals well yeah that's part
of treating them better
yeah yeah it would work that way um
married men have cats
um some
married men have cats some cats have
married men
yes one needs to the meaning there is
ambiguous but yes
yeah all right okay um let's do
three more how about and we'll stop for
today i've heard you guys talk about
coronavirus yes yes
we have rather a lot coronavirus seems
to be misrepresented as a cold instead
of a
blood disease also i've read that this
virus is impulse
and affects the consciousness what are
your opinions on this
i certainly believe that uh
respiratory virus is
almost a holdover to the early
discussion
when the fact that that is the way it is
typically contracted
dominated our thought about the the
particular pathology and now you know
one of the things that was revealed
pretty early on
was that there are a huge range of
symptoms of this thing
that extend to uh many many different
systems in the body and so yes
many of them not respiratory yeah many
of them are not respiratory and
uh you know it will affect consciousness
will it affect it directly
i don't know i doubt it but um will it
affect it indirectly
sure i mean even in some cases i mean
you're given that it affects the senses
um and uh you know we have yeah
living right next door to you know sort
of encode consciousness
um in in the brain um yes presumably
it's possible well i think you i think
you've just landed on a
a certain one which is given the number
of people who lose their
sense of smell and taste that cannot
help but affect consciousness
likewise happy hypoxics
uh you know being comfortable
as you are in jeopardy of your uh
blood oxygenation level dropping to a
critically dangerous level will also
have effects on that in other words
you're
not super capable but you may not know
it so anyway
these things will all have indirect
effects on consciousness is it
invading the neurons involved in
consciousness probably not
yeah it would be unlikely to yeah and um
our first i think like 16 episodes uh
were all
almost entirely about about coven and
coronavirus
and we made a habit of going back when
we
made errors that we knew about in the
next episode so um
although we haven't gone back and
listened to them since at least i
haven't i don't think you have
we stand by that and um with the
understanding that
everyone's understanding of what it is
is changing and has changed
um but that we were careful then and we
you know we have
many many hours of talking about
coronavirus yep and i think actually one
of the things i'm proudest about
is the way in which our model
improved over time and actually gave
people what i think stands up as a
description of how to
maintain your life in the midst of covid
and not get sick
so anyway it wasn't perfect but um but i
think
the proof that paying attention to this
stuff and wielding
tools that are perfectly at home in a
you know public non-professional
context uh was enough to get a pretty
good model that was way ahead of the cdc
um and uh anyway yeah it was good stuff
i think
good okay what is the evolutionary
juxtaposition between comedy and tragedy
also what role does comedy play in terms
of creating a shared reality and
building trust inside communities
amongst each other
you've sort of answered your own
question haven't you it does exactly
that
yeah um i'm sorry did you want to say
that there is no
top evolutionary juxtaposition of comedy
i mean
in some sense comedy
almost requires a recognition
that what is at stake is limited
and tragedy the thing that seems to
characterize
a a narrative tragedy
is that the bottom drops out and that
things that could have been
navigated because of the tragic flaw of
the hero or whatever
everything is lost
so i guess i would say both of these
things
are narrative forms the reason that they
are narrative forms is because
there are important lessons that they
carry and probably each
is capable you know a comedy presumably
leaves us better able to understand our
our own personal foibles and therefore
be better to each other a tragedy allows
us to understand that there may be a
great deal more at stake than we can see
from
our limited vantage point and that we
would be wise to pay attention to those
hazards
but i would say you look any any
standard form
exists because it taught certain things
that
were worth the cost of that form and
maybe there's something beyond that but
i think as a starter that that does it
yeah all right um two more
basically just comments here um i hang
out with people in real life who find
racist jokes hilarious
my best friends are mexicans they laugh
at jokes that are funny but true
we are not racists we are just funny
people ps we grew up on the chappelle
show chichen chang and blazing saddles
i actually want to correct that a little
bit those don't sound like
racist jokes those are
racial jokes and i would agree i mean
you know the number of jewish jokes that
jews tell
you know that have some sort of content
about
you know about what jews are like is
many and
to lose this is and whereas
you know jews aren't telling
anti-semitic jokes right
they may be telling jewish jokes right
yeah yeah
absolutely um so anyway
look we've lost our best tools and
frankly
this is why i jumped to this one that
you know it's about comedy again right
like
right comedy is necessary it's not just
useful it's necessary
yeah so you know we navigate this stuff
in ways and the idea that we're going to
scrutinize everything
and you know figure out which things are
still tolerable because you know
yes you know racist jokes
will be a subset of racial
jokes right yeah they will be within
that set
um i don't know anybody who can tell you
the rule
that says where the sort of permissible
stuff
stops and the impermissible stuff starts
which means we have to be a bit generous
with each other in order to find out
where that is and wouldn't it be
interesting to
discover that border and what better you
know you're going to need
humor in order to figure it out so
anyway um
yes we are trying to write rules for
things that are so
mysterious and subtle that it it's folly
in the first place
um indeed yeah one last question yeah
brett are you yet in 2021 i
think so it's a little harder to tell
because when you're the one
lagging it's not like there's fanfare or
people aren't you know
setting off uh fireworks in the night
when you transition between one year and
the next but i do feel that i am now
solidly in 2021 and it sucks
every bit as much as 2020 did so far
well welcome thank you we've been
awaiting you
we're hoping that you have some
solutions ah yes
well um i've got some stuff i will sort
through it and see if there's anything
solution like
in it good all right very good
very good here we are at the end again
yes
at the end so all the usual stuff you
can buy
um dark horse merchandise
at the store you see it on screen there
join us at our patreons please private q
a will be the last sunday of the month
and your conversations are the first
saturday and sunday of the month
and you get access to our discord and
you can find clips
on the dark horse podcast clips channel
and various other true things yes uh
hang in there we
are by my calculations more than one
sixth of the way through winter
yes we are more than one sixth of the
way through winter so it's uh
it's it's rushing by at an incredible
rate we will
with all almost a third of the way
through winter
[Music]
yeah i guess we are closer we're closing
in on uh on a third
um but in any case chances are we're
going to survive winter again
so that's good news yeah yep it is
all right be well everyone we will get
outside even though for most of you it's
winter
[Music]
you